welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Boss and this is a breakdown of Marvel's
what if season 2 episode 8 what if the
Avengers assembled in 1602 Loosely based
on the 2003 Marvel 16028 issue comic
series written by Neil Gaiman this
episode transports our Avengers to
Elizabeth and England and I'm going to
break down all the Easter eggs animation
details and other stuff that you might
have missed including the unspoken but
really cool reason why 1602 London was
the cosmic destination for these Heroes
and this theater nerd was thrilled to
realize it now I am still technically on
paternity leave I'm sorry kid Jessica
Clemens has been so wonderful breaking
down the first six episodes of the
season but she is feeling under the
weather so I'm pitching back in huge
thanks to her and to John Costa and to
Noah chin for their help with these
breakdowns these have been a team effort
and I'm so grateful to everyone at new
rock stars this episode opens in
London's Globe Theater 1602 with Loki
reciting Shakespeare's Hamlet act three
scene one the famous quote to be or not
to be that is a question whether it is
noer in the mind to suffer the slings
and arrows of Outrageous Fortune or take
arms against a sea of troubles and by
opposing end them so this Soliloquy is
coming from Hamlet the prince of Denmark
pondering ending his own life as he
deals with the anguish of his father's
death by the hands of his treacherous
Uncle Claudius who sees the throne in
the aftermath and the Hand of his mother
Gertrude but the fact that it's Loki
performing this role is no coincidence
as the spurned adopted brother he was
long denied the throne and he had a
complex relationship with his mother fra
Loki later this episode cites Doo the
envious schemer of Shakespeare's the
fellow which truly is the more apt role
for the god of Mischief but we know from
Thor Ragnarok that Loki is a lover of
historical theatrical reenactments on
the stage which Shakespeare's histories
were and remember when Tony Stark first
met Thor in Avengers 2012 he mocked Thor
in Thor's brother Loki's Forest dispute
as Shakespeare in the park does mother
know you weareth her drapes but there is
a deeper reason why the MCU Loki
especially recently would love to be
here right now this quote from Hamlet
underscores the broader dance mob with
existence all these Marvel heroes are
going through including the Watcher this
kind of describes their wrestling with
reality in this episode as this universe
is doomed to die on its current
trajectory that's why it's fitting to
open this episode with the image of the
skull of yoro but a little nitpick here
Hamlet does not hold the skull of yoro
during this scene that actually comes
later in the play act 5 scene 1 Alas
poor yoro I knew him Horatio a fellow of
infinite chest yoro was Hamlet's old
Jester who died many years past and in
subsequent art the skull of yoro has
come to symbolize the concept of momento
Mori remember you shall die the idea
that we are all Mortal even the silly
ones who never took themselves too
seriously like yor and notice how on the
stage with Loki is a dead tree which is
interesting given his variant fate as
the god of stories in the errill tree of
time a tree that looks healthier than
ever from the Queen's box Thor heckles
while Queen Hela laughs along sitting
upon the throne flanked by advisers sir
Hogan and Sir Nick Fury all of this is
really an alteration from the Marvel
1602 Comics the what if sliding doors
hypothetical of this episode is actually
a mystery revealed only in the final
minutes and it is what if Steve Rogers
during Infinity War ruptured the time
Stone and caused the modern Avengers to
respawn in Elizabeth in London Steve
Rogers is the Forerunner character in
The 1602 Comics but it's really due to
different events in the future the
purple man kilgrave becomes a dictator
president for life and Steve Rogers is
sent back in time to erase the purple
man's Legacy but he gets captured by
Native Americans who mistake his name as
roaz and he serves as a bodyguard of the
young Virginia Dare who is the first
child born in the brono colony and is
brought back to England this all results
in the multiversal Rifts that threaten
this universe which is later contained
within a gym and renamed by The Watcher
as Earth 311 in the comics Hela isn't
the Monarch the historical tutor
monarchs are Elizabeth and James and
it's not a captain Carter story but they
repurposed it here for the what if
Series in which Captain Peggy Carter is
really the focal character so here the
green Rift opens and Loki trying to
finish the Soliloquy shouts these
important words The Dread of something
after death the Undiscovered Country no
Trav returns yeah this comes from a
little bit later in the hamlet passage
but that the dread of something after
death the Undiscovered Country from
whose born no traveler returns puzzles
the will and makes us rather bear those
ills we have then fly to others we know
not of by Undiscovered Country Hamlet is
referring to an unknown afterlife either
heaven or hell and it's really the
perfect part of the passage to shout as
Loki's being sucked into a possible hell
mouth in the sky so Peggy's able to save
Loki but she Los es the queen Hela and
so everyone bends the knee to the new
king Thor odinson who now carries hela's
Emerald en crusted scepter it is similar
to the scepter that Loki carried in the
first Avengers film which contain an
infinity stone the Mind Stone but the
green gem here is actually implied to be
a piece of the time Stone by the end of
the episode and it could be why this
Rift sucked in Hela and Loki in
particular as it's just the time Stone
and temporal radiation trying to heal
itself in patch itself but King Thor
blames Captain Carter and she steals the
irradiated yoro skull poor yor a subtle
to that act five scene one line alas po
York The Watcher explains that Captain
Carter was brought into this dying 1602
Universe by the Scarlet Witch Wanda
maximoff who in this episode is called
Merlin Wanda after Merlin the Wizard of
King Arthur and of course this explains
why Peggy fell through that Crimson
portal at the end of episode five you'll
notice Peggy now wears metal pauldrons
and other armor pieces every character
in this episode is wearing interesting
armor versions of the suits that we've
seen them wear in the MCU but with Peggy
it's just interesting that this hero in
blazing with the Union Jack would come
here the Union Jack wouldn't become the
official flag of the UK until 1801 but
the imagery of the flag does go as far
back to 16006 when James the who was
formerly James I 6 of Scotland inherited
the English throne and you could say
ruled over England and Scotland and
Ireland in a personal Union even if all
three were still considered separate
states I just like the idea that Captain
Carter might have inspired that design
in this timeline but again there doesn't
seem to be any tutor Dynasty in this
reality this reality was formed by cap
striking the time Stone and spawning
this new timeline line where 21st
century Heroes were just sent to this
particular point in history and then
just began to occupy various roles in
the social hierarchy kind of like a
house of M reality as opposed to a
sliding doors timeline that fit in with
English society in a political structure
as it was so the Watcher now says Peggy
is a fugitive from King Thor on the run
with no way home yeah naturally he would
use the title of an MCU multiversal
crossover movie to describe Peggy's
predicament but the Watcher is surprised
that Peggy can hear his narration this
elevates Peggy the status of strange
Supreme and Ultron infinity and as of I
am Groot season 2 Groot all beings that
could hear the Watcher and you might say
Nexus level beings The Watcher says
worlds die every day I've watched
Millions fade from existence I find it
interesting that he said millions and
not billions or even trillions as folks
like Kang the Conqueror have burned that
many people out of time through their
actions but back in the year 1600 the
world population was only 554 million
and I like how the Watcher literally
Fades out of this scene right as Peggy
says she won't let this universe fade
made from existence thank you to geology
for partnering with us to bring you this
video and also for giving our audiences
exclusive access to their new try before
you buy program you've probably heard me
mention geology before the 28 time
award-winning skin hair and body care
company recognized in men's health hype
Beast birdie Esquire ask men and Oprah
daily grooming Awards but hey I get it
it can be tough to change a skincare
routine or start a new one part of
what's nice about galy is they create
simple and effective skincare and Hair
Care routines customized just for you
and now if you want to try that new
routine out before you buy a bunch of
stuff you can geology is offering new
rockstars viewers a free trial of their
eight-piece skincare set with their try
before you buy a program you can
experience a new skincare routine
risk-free for 14 days if you don't love
it send it back it's that easy the set
is valued at $139 all you pay today is
the price of shipping and if you order
today get a free vitamin C plus e feric
acid as a gift you don't need to return
it that's yours just head to geology.com
neww rockstars and get your free trial
and geology will send you a personalized
skincare routine and if you don't mind
me I'm going to take some geology and uh
uh look good for the rest of this video
king Thor small Council reports losses
to these Rifts and all these locations
are named after random MCU figures like
nebula's Observatory the aisle of ego
groot's Groves known for its wines I
suppose nebula would be looking out for
Thanos and other Cosmic threats and I
like how ego is just an island instead
of an entire planet happy growls at wed
predicting the Forerunner would be
coming from the future and we see his
skin just begin to turn a shap of purple
it also turns his shade later during the
raid on the Treehouse and all of this is
foreshadowing his inner form of the
freak like we saw in episode 3 of the
season and I'm enjoying how the wh if
writers have decided that this is just a
core part of happy Hogan now in Stark's
Workshop you can see that he is building
a suit of armor with wings and a chest
mounted disc making this a 1602 Iron Man
suit because they wouldn't have jet
propulsion technology yet the only way
this thing could fly is if it had wings
kind of like a Buzz Lightyear type of
suit and to the left of that is actually
a shield with a star reminding reming us
of how his Malibu basement Workshop had
a version of Captain America shield that
he was working on hanging from above is
a helmet with a t- visor that looks like
a Mandalorian helmet which I think might
just be a John Fabro shout out and to
the right of Peggy in the reverse shot
is a helmet that looks like Tony's
original mark1 helmet repurposed for OB
stain's Iron Monger suit but this
version of Tony is still working on his
Mark 1 Elizabethan armor and when Tony
faints you can actually see a hammer
that looks like Meir though this might
just be a blacksmith Hammer that he's
using to forge all this stuff but later
Thor asks Loki where the camera is and
Loki says he misplaced it so this might
actually be M here they examine the
irradiated parts of yoro skull and fun
fact the microscope was actually
invented in 1590 I don't think it looked
exactly like this but you know a brain
like Tony Starks would be able to build
on the existing technology of the time
Peggy keeps dropping future technology
terms around Tony and he loves it and
just to please them she just says fux
capacitor which tells us that among her
list of modern pop culture that she's
been consuming that she talked about
with Natasha in episode 5 was the film
Back to the Future a film series that
was cited in Avengers endgame whenever
these characters try to explain how time
travel works in the MCU Loki tells these
women that will has written a new play
and he mentions Iago of course the
villainous tragic hero in aelo athel was
published in the year 16003 so this
being 1602 would make this the new play
that William Shakespeare was currently
working on at this time but Loki's
Carriage is raided by Steve Rogers AKA
Rogers Hood with his merry men including
Scott Lang and Bucky Barnes these two
did join team cap in Civil War now the
historical figure of Robin Hood he was
actually a real guy actually lived in
England back in the 12th century and we
learned that 1602 Peggy Carter died in
this universe setting up the heart of
this episode as the love between Steve
and Peggy he asks her about her Universe
of Steve Rogers tell me what he's
like no I I don't think I will oh she
says the same line that old Steve Rogers
says to Sam Wilson in endgame when Sam
asks what his other life was like but in
this case it's really just because
Peggy's too heartbroken that skinny
Steve became the Hydra stomper assassin
Hogan crashes their secret treehouse
with an army of Roy Royal Yellow Jackets
now not sure if they're all Darren Cross
or if they're soldiers who have
replicated this technology Hogan fires
them out of an old timey pistol it's
kind of like how Hawkeye attached Scott
Lang to his arrow in Civil War Scott
Lang says oh great it's that freak Hogan
reminding us that Hogan has that inner
freak that's been trying to break out
during the brawl I love how Peggy and
Steve share Peggy's Union Jack shields
in these kind of shared attacks like
Steve kind of instinctively knows when
and how to dodge a shield when it
boomerangs back at him Hogan uses the
Destroyer armor from the first Thor film
that's the weapon from Odin's Vault that
Loki Unleashed on Thor in New Mexico
outside the Tower of London the
Executioner is sharpening his axe and we
see that it is Red Skull so facing
defeat Peggy asks the watch over help
but he poses this run of questions what
if the world doesn't magically correct
itself what if it's the final straw that
destroys this universe what if when the
universe resets you're trapped here
forever what if you die what if what if
what if yes she just repeats the title
of the series and yeah it really seems
like Captain Carter is just becoming
more and more more of a meta Nexus
character alongside the Watcher and
strange Supreme Peggy locates in another
cell the monster in the Iron Mask and
for a second I was like is this Victor
Von Doom but no it is Bruce Banner with
the Iron Mask presumably designed to
contain the Hulk and I like the idea
that Stark may have designed this mask
similar to Tony and different realities
helping Bruce devise a Hulk anti-serum
to better control that Hulk form Peggy
and Bruce return to Stark's Workshop
where you can see more sketches on the
wall for his Elizabethan armor in the
wings and the circular centerpiece which
definitely seems like an old school Arc
Reactor whenever he would get around to
inventing it and he might have but it
seems like Stark spent the night after
drinking some grain alcohol another hint
that yeah this Stark is going through
his own demon in a bottle storyline here
this device that will reveal the
Forerunner once the Royal Stone from the
scepter is inserted and send him back
and right when he says this in this
moment 1602 Steve walks in foreshadowing
that it is a Steve Rogers who is the
Forerunner so this team infiltrates King
Thor's Court into disguise and the rift
opens Wanda tries to contain it the
melee begins Scott tells Bucky that
they'll teach everyone the dance maob
the dance maab refers to an allegorical
artistic genre from the late Middle Ages
that would often depict the dead dancing
to the Grave which is really another
icon of that term I brought up before
momento Mory much like York skull while
hulk smashes his guards he grunts Dash
your puny Gods recalling when he called
Loki a puny God in the 2012 Avengers
meanwhile Steve slices the feather in
Hogan's cap which is the final straw
that causes him to finally hulke out
into the freak King Thor requests the
Alla which is the name he gave his sword
which Peggy recognizes as vibranium and
Thor says the king of Wanda gave it as a
coronation gift which reminds us how in
episode 2 we learned that the vibranium
of the original Captain America shield
was given to Howard Stark as a gift by
tachaka father in the 1940s and this
reminds us that all the way back to the
year 1602 wakanda was there and wakanda
had vibranium and was keeping an eye on
world events now throughout this fight
Hogan drops a string of old timey
insults and terms at both Steve and
Bruce and Bruce just grabs him by the
head and throws him into the church
organ and when he throws the organ back
at him he says the pipes the pipes are
calling alluding to the verses of the
old Irish song odan boy sir Fury gets
the scepter from Thor and star extracts
the green gem to activate this device
which Peggy does by plunging her hands
into the box functioning the same exact
way as the mark 5 suitcase suit from
Iron Man 2 and the blast from a gauntlet
freezes the Marvel heroes in time and
the Forerunner finally appears and it is
Steve Rogers he takes it back to his
duel with Thanos in the Battle of
wakanda in Infinity War when Steve had
the black vibranium gauntlets given to
him by tchala and here he strikes the
time Stone but what's odd here is that
when cap first confronted Thanos in
Infinity War remember Thanos had not yet
acquired the mindstone from vision's
forehead that would come moments after
Thanos repelled Steve but the mindstone
is in the gauntlet here so in this
alternate universe version of the battle
Steve would get back up and dual Thanos
again remember the guy can do this all
day and would get in one last round with
mad Titan and that it would be Steve
Rogers not Thor who got in that final
one-on-one with the guy so really what
they're saying here is that Steve's
green color here plus the green Rifts in
the sky the green gem in the scepter the
fact that they've all Frozen all these
are really just meant to convey that
this entire 1602 universe is a cosmic
aberation caused by the damage to the
time Stone you could even say all this
is contained within that chunk of the
time Stone that's why the circumstances
of this episode are so unlike every
other instance of time travel or
timeline manipulation we've seen in the
MCU they are really just an accident
caused by Cosmic radiation veering off
in some other way that time Stone
radiation caused certain Marvel heroes
from 2018 to go back to the year 1602
and fit into these different corners of
the English social hierarchy but why
that time and place in particular well
When You Subtract 1602 from 2018 you get
616 I'm just kidding it's just 416 years
I'm sorry to do that to you but here's
what I think the reason is I believe
it's because this is the era of William
Shakespeare arguably the most productive
period of dramatic storytelling at least
in the English language because the
works of William Shakespeare were
perhaps the most influential
contribution to the way our society to
this day understands narrative and sees
our lives through dramatic lenses now
you may not agree with that and you you
might believe that there are plenty of
other artistic periods throughout world
history that were more important but I
am just looking at this Through The Eyes
of one MCU character who is more
important than any other character right
now Loki that is the character with whom
we started this episode he is the mcu's
reigning God of stories who is currently
thrown at the heart of idril an image
that we know we will see in tomorrow's
finale I believe it was Loki's control
over time that displaced Marvel heroes
back to these years in particular to the
era of Shakespeare that could be why
Loki even joined them here despite
remember Loki being dead after Thanos
snapped his neck to get that space Stone
in the events leading up to Steve
striking that time Stone there must have
been some other Loki at work there and I
think it was that one the god of stories
in eill now Peggy tells Steve that they
never got their happy ending and Steve
says I'm sure somewhere out there we do
and the final shut of end game proves
that some other version of them will
finally get that dance and I'll admit my
interpretation that this whole episode
is about the history of Storytelling
might just be how I'm looking at things
has someone clearly obsessed with the
Loki finale but it is worth noting that
the final seconds of this episode shows
strange Supreme finding this stranded
Captain Carter in 16002 and telling her
this oh peg I got a story to tell you a
story to tell you and we end with to be
continued as tomorrow's finale will be
what if strange Supreme intervened so
our dear friend Jessica Clemens is still
feeling a bit unwell so I may be hosting
tomorrow's finale breakdown but please
please please go back to watch her
incredible breakdowns in the first six
episodes of the season and keep an eye
out for our upcoming what if inspired
series looking at real world type of
thing IAL starting with what if Edgar
Wright directed Ant-Man I think you're
going to love that video subscribe to
all three channels in the new rockstars
Network you can follow me at eaos
support us with some exclusive merch
From Nerd rot. shop it's the best way to
support us thanks for watching and I'll
see you next time
bye